okay it's time to go oh scream
[Applause]
yes Schiff got kicked to the curb and
the irony is superb he went crying to
Mommy on an app run by Chinese commies
congressman Adam Schiff announced this
morning he's running for U.S Senate in
California which is guaranteed to boost
U-Haul rentals headed for Texas
he unveiled the highly polished and
produced political ad right on the heels
of getting booted from the house Intel
committee coincidence I think not yeah
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy removed
shift from his intelligence duties this
week citing National Security concerns
go ahead you can applaud that
foreign
yes that and the fact that ship hasn't
blinked since 1992.
I didn't take the news so well the
disgraced Democrat went on Tick Tock to
complain behold
hello I'm congressman Adam Schiff with
some troubling news today Kevin McCarthy
removed me from the house intelligence
committee all for doing my job for
holding Trump accountable and standing
up to the extreme Mega Republicans we
knew it would be bad when the
Republicans took over but it's far worse
than we expected cue the violins people
but can he promise you this
but I can promise you this this is not
the end of my fight for our democracy
this is just the beginning please join
us and contribute today thank you
here's my question how much will it cost
for you not to run
yeah but does Schiff even see the irony
as a little video he's talking about
fighting for democracy and doing his job
on the intelligence committee on tick
tock a Chinese owned social media site
so Schiff is rightly getting blasted for
that and you know I didn't even know
Adam had a tick tock account I wonder
what other videos he's made
you oh my God
will be
popular
you're gonna be popular
[Music]
yeah
they're going bad
you could have a new career Joe uh so do
you are you excited that he's running
no just get him out of there I mean the
whole the whole idea like you said of
him putting it on Tick Tock when that
shows you right there that he does not
understand what it takes to be on the
intelligence committee Tick Tock is
that's like saying uh check out my my
op-ed on Russian aggression in the new
issue of Pravda
you don't trust the enemies to do uh
your job for you so I think it and as
soon as we can get him out of there and
I do like that McCarthy he backed up
what he said he showed some spine that
we weren't expecting that he got him out
of there and he got swallow out of there
who was alleged to have an affair with a
Chinese spy uh name I'm sure the name
was Fang Fang or Fang Fang Fang Fang I'm
not sure how many things there's a lot
of things in there these guys are clowns
get them out if it's the spoil system
it's the same thing Pelosi and the
Democrats do when they took over
Lauren
I think he's obviously with the tick
tock he thinks maybe the young people
out there and maybe you can raise money
off of them is that the idea I think so
it's so awkward it's so awkward look I
get tick tocks Where It's At by the way
it's banned on government devices in
more than half the country and some
major universities like the University
of Texas at Austin have banded even on
their Wi-Fi on the kids like personal
devices so it's it's to get the younger
voters interests which sort of makes
sense but the if you ask a young person
what do you think about Tick Tock where
the Chinese potentially spying on you
and knowing what you're doing even when
you're not using the app because they're
in your phone they kind of don't care I
think a lot of people would agree with
that right we threw privacy out the
window a long time ago in this age of um
of of devices and constantly being
hooked up
but I that might be starting to switch
so maybe some young people are going to
say okay I'm not into Tick Tock as much
anymore maybe there's something newer
that's coming along maybe we don't like
he's running for Senate now to replace
Dianne Feinstein who's 89 years old so I
mean
she still gets around though Feinstein
he's going for a whole different voter
but Jamie you are on The Cutting Edge of
Technology what kind of platforms do you
use to promote your career you know me
I've been on Tick Tock since I read this
story
and
um I wish we could see the thing again
because I don't think anyone's giving
him credit for doing that entire speech
with a globe balanced on his head
that's right just isn't it also
I don't like announcing important thing
it just seems like the cheapest like to
announce it on Tick Tock to me even
seems cheap and then like even running
for Senate he did that on Twitter like
why can't what I don't know it just
feels like that would be like going like
I'm filing this lawsuit gentlemen bring
me my Etch A Sketch
yeah that's just embarrassing it's very
true and also when you like lose a
position or lose a job or a girl breaks
up with you the move is always to be
graceful and not to go on and complain I
watch this video on closed caption it
just said boohoo
um
like I
I always treat with her even when I get
like I got fired I had a job at the
unemployment office and uh when I got
fired I was like fine I'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Laughter]
really
they like that hey you can go ahead and
was it that was it the fourth one that
did it
Emily the uh I know people are you know
Tick Tock they say oh it's dangerous
done by the Chinese but you know all
these other platforms Google's stealing
our information too I don't trust them
the thing that's bad about Tick Tock is
it takes away people's information it
kind of rots your brain because you're
spending all day doing stupid videos and
looking at the stupid videos right right
and you know part of the issue is that
it's been codified in China as of 2017
that every single private citizen in
every single business has to work in
tandem with cccp to share data so
literally these platforms by law have to
work with the CCP and share the data of
most of our youth and the fact that this
guy gets on it by the way that was his
first Tick Tock video oh wow and his
first Tick Tock video after being booted
from the intelligence committee was to
get on Tick Tock and say how he was
qualified I mean this is like after you
you don't let your teenager drive the
car because they haven't done
demonstrated responsibility and then
they take it anyway and crash it and
claim that they still have that
responsibility you know he's a steward
of our taxpayer dollars we've been
paying this guy and secretary Pompeo let
the world know that this one basically
leaked classified information so not
only has he lied to the American public
under our watch and our dollars but he's
really undergone some potentially
felonious activity and he wants us to
pay him now more to run for Senate and
as the wapo warns he might get then a
position on this Senate intelligence
committee I don't know what's more
frightening that or him on these videos
only fans I mean I don't know I don't
know what's worse oh that would be
trouble wouldn't it Joe I think uh he he
actually was pretty wise though because
he got all attention we're doing the
story right yeah I think is it on Tick
Tock and he got a lot of headlines I'm
impressed with the angle he got to make
his neck look even skinnier than usual
it's really it looks like a like a
balloon I was waiting for someone to let
go in his head which is going to float
off
lollipop so true yeah oh there's the
Globe back there you're right Jamie hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else